nous maxime vivas administrateurs du
site le grand soir point info maxime
vivas bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france le venezuela
rejette un rapport de l'onu qui pointe
l'affaiblissement de son système
judiciaire on vient de le voir quel est
le message lancé par la communauté
internationale à travers ce rapport
alors d'abord je pense que c'est un
rapport qui est d'un petit nombre de
pays membres de l'onu ce n'est pas la
communauté internationale en a
l'habitude de l'appeler communauté
internationale en général des pays
attentiste mais bon il ya cinq ans de
plus de 190 pays qui sont membres de
l'onu je pense qu'ils n'ont pas toutes
la même position vis-à-vis de du
venezuela et notamment je pense à des
pays très important qui compte des
milliards d'habitants au total comme la
chine la russie
donc voici non ce n'est pas vraiment une
une condamnation de la communauté
internationale si tu n'as qu'une
condamnation d'un comité membres de
l'onu et qui capte qui pointerait la
justice mme bérès revienne parce qu en
fait de toutes les autres moyenne tous
les autres ags d'attac qui ont été
essayées depuis l'annexion de chavez en
1998 tous ont essayé et je crois que la
justice est le dernier il ya eu contre
chavez en 2002 un putsch il ya eu des
tentatives d'assassinât et des commandos
ont été arrêtés à quelques dizaines de
km de caracas dans les chefs avait dit à
l'époque que leur mission était de
couper la tête de chavez il y a eu le 12
mai la tentative d'invasion une sorte de
baie des cochons
tyrone robes et les aliens il ya le
sabotage de l'économie vénézuélienne
il ya maintenant le blocus imposé par
les états unis
il y à des tentatives de faire soulever
l'armée quan ba yo a participé à des
attaques de casernes et puis il y avait
il ya eu des tentatives de faire
soulever le peuple mais comme le peuple
va dans la rue
malheureusement pour eux c'est pour
soutenir le gouvernement en place
donc est ce qu'il reste mais il reste
attaqué la justice empêchent-ils bleus
gouvernement vénézuélien de pouvoir
faire appliquer la loi et de faire en
sorte que ce ne s'inscrivait pas dans le
respect de la loi soient punis vous
l'avez évoqué à froid de gouaille doha
est cité à comparaître devant le
ministère public et dans le cadre d'une
enquête pour tentative de coup d'état
contre le président nicholas maduro
erwan guyot peut-il toujours compter sur
ses soutiens en europe et aux états unis
alors je crois aux états unis je crois
que commence à faiblir en europe oui
parce que quand on continue à considérer
en europe que les pays d'amérique latine
aux en plus ou moins des colonies
françaises et européennes et donc aulas
comme ça une sorte de deux de vision un
peu colonialiste mais donc quang huy
goyau a été reçue par le temps le par le
parlement et par les autorités
européennes
il a été reçu aussi par le président
macron est ce qu'elle sera ordinaire
c'est qu'en fait il se revendique comme
président du venezuela
alors que le président élu
démocratiquement
ces modes gros et qu'il a été élu contre
deux adversaires qui ont été défaits
mais que mais que bordeaux n'était même
pas candidat il n'était pas candidat
peut pas dire qu'il a été vaincu qui a
eu une fraude
il a eu zéro voix parce qu'il n'était
pas candidat dont il se proclame
président je pense que dans n'importe
quel pays du monde
parce qu'en plus ils appellent ils
appellent l'armée étasunienne à venir à
venir en baïse à envahir le venezuela
je pense que ça n'est pas de quel pays
du monde il sera en prison voilà alors
vous l'avez vous l'avez dit emmanuel
marolle l'a reçu à l'elysée un croix de
guido en janvier dernier lui affirmant
son soutien quels sont les intérêts de
la france dans cette crise politique
vénézuélienne malheureusement je pense
que la france n ont que l'intérêt mais
la france est dans une position de suivi
des ententistes comme l'europe leur
europe n'est pas une entité indépendante
l'europe est une sorte de succursale les
états unis d'amérique et ce qui est bon
pour les états unis d'amérique
les feux les européens croient que c'est
bon pour eux mais cette ignorance est
une grave erreur
nous n'avons aucun intérêt nous avoir
des gars dit
ni regret que latine je crois que
d'avoir le samedi l'auteur nous aussi et
procès et la france a une frontière
commune maritime avec le venezuela
donc nous avons des intérêts plutôt
avoir des bons rapports avec le
gouvernement démocratique élu du
venezuela
et ce n'est pas ce que ce qui ce qui se
fait parce que l'intérêt des états unis
c'est tout à fait différent vous savez
moi j'étais en 2007 au venezuela et j'ai
bu des manifestations ou les y avait des
grandes banderoles qui disaient peuple
ne trompe pas le problème ce n'est pas
chavez
c'est le pétrole y en a finalement
grille actuellement on voit ça au petit
peuple ne trompe pas le problème ce
n'est pas ma gourou c'est le pétrole
merci beaucoup maxime vivas d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes
l'administrateur du site internet grands
soirs point info